der nächste bitte bis an den thomas
hennig
jonas ja das bin ich
mein name ist lukas wieder von alex
events im auftrag von wortmann media
organisiert er eine kampagne zum thema
agenten festlege ich wollte sie etwas
fragen
ich muss
da können wir die pflege super die
stecke ich gleich meinen für morgen auf
geht's du darfst das lokal aufsuchen
sie würden mir wärmstens von jucu
empfohlen und die lage des restaurants
ist für uns perfekt restaurant
ich kann ihnen frikadellen brater
toiletten anbieten und vielleicht
leckeren kartoffelsalat saison mit gold
und kürbiskernen herzhafte krank gefühlt
mit ziegenkäse kirschtomaten und rucola
vorweg ein zu chemischen und als dessert
ein basilikum
ja das hat sich alles ganz verlockend an
auch die frikadellen vielleicht von
allem etwas tun sie sich ruhig aus sie
haben freie hand wir werden wohl ab 20
personen kommen die sich hier aufhalten
müssen aber jetzt auch mehr ist meinen
tisch zwei personen suchen sich einen
aus zwar stand kreis schon mal klar
den neuen laden habe ich mir irgendwie
ein bisschen anders vorgestellt ist
davon halten könntest du nicht
ich gerade romantisch die gehen aus
house danke post posten schon alex nicht
spielen
ich dachte ich könnte das schöne mit dem
nützlichen fallen
sag mal hast du hast vor lauter gehört
sie ist schon seit stunden weg eine
handy geht sie auch nicht nicht dass da
was passiert ist
wem etwas passiert
wenn ich einen schlüssel hätte dann wäre
die flasche schon kalt was gibt es denn
zu feiern
das wachstum ab heute ist mir das schon
erzählen können meinst du nicht
herzlichen glückwunsch sie sind wir eher
ich freue mich für dich
hey ich soll das gesicht für eure riesen
kampagne werden und du sagst mir nichts
ja das ist toll
du willst gar nicht dass ich das machen